alors c'est ainsi que naissent les
chapeaux et les vêtements c'est montini
montigny de vie c'est là que j'existe en
fait oui à travers les matériaux que
j'aime qui sont des beaux matériaux de
de france ou d'italie 6 et de la paille
mais des matériaux de créateurs voilà
evelyne et modiste
elle aime les modèles uniques et le sur
mesure avant le chapeau il faut faire
tremper les brins d'osier dans de l'eau
pendant ce temps elle passe de la praye
à l'intérieur du cône de feutre pour le
rigidifier effectivement le feutre
certains maintien mais ça serait pas
suffisant avec le temps sont des choses
qui se porte quand même souvent sous la
pluie sous la neige
ensuite direction les toilettes ou le
feutre va faire un sauna de 20 minutes
au dessus d'un couscous y est c'est le
moment de mouler le chapeau sur sa forme
c'est evelyne qu'il a créé c'est
vraiment prendre forme
épouser la forme du j'aime beaucoup ça
épouser la forme du moule
est ce que ça se travaille assez
rapidement parce que le footsie est
refroidi je peux plus le travailler
ça c'est ma signature
voilà donc monsieur est posée sur son
gigolo et va sécher pendant ce temps
evelyne assemble un chapeau pour hommes
d'abord installé une corde à piano dont
le bord pour le maintien la couture est
un moment à histoire après je vais aller
piquer mon bord sur pétronille ma
vieille machine à piquer les la paille a
piqué les feutres aussi gelé baptisé
comme ça parce qu en fait personne qui a
créé les chapeaux de paille et est ce
qu'on m'a raconté j'aime beaucoup cette
histoire était une bergère qui un jour
s'ennuyer et s'est amusé à dresser de la
paille et à coudre la paille à faire les
premiers canotiers et moi je les
appelais du nom de la bergère être ni
l'après midi evelyne travail et les
clientes souvent devenues amies passe
chercher leurs bonnets d'automne on
essaie des chapeaux de toutes les
couleurs je me dis voilà j'ai été
attirée par lui
et puis je l'essayé evelyne la miyama à
ma taille
l'atelier dave est un endroit situé
entre les années 20 et les années
soixante dix a lieu des changes de rêve
de poésie et de belles matières evelyne
m fabriquer des chapeaux
mais aussi des robes de mariée il ya de
recevoir le tissu pour celles de
laëtitia
elle sera blanche le tissu soeur à
soyaux très soyeux
pour le reste c'est un secret